New fundraising totals are
giving us insight
into which Republican
candidates are gaining steam
and who is falling behind.
Those numbers
are even more important than usual
since small donors
will help decide
whether Republican
candidates can make the debate stage
next month.
And joining me now is a candidate
who says he has already met
those fundraising requirements, former
New Jersey Governor Chris Christie.
Governor Christie, thanks for joining us.
Your campaign reports
having raised $1.7 million
in the first 25 days
of your presidential bid.
That's more than Mike Pence.
But behind
not only Donald Trump and Ron DeSantis,
but also Nikki Haley and Tim Scott.
They were in the race longer than you.
We should note.
But you are going to have to do a lot
better than that in the next quarter.
So how are you going to achieve that?
Well, look, Jake, if
we continue to raise money at the pace
we've been raising it,
we're going to do just fine.
I mean, as you noted, Tim Scott transfer
the significant amount of money
from his Senate campaign.
Nikki Haley, he's been in the race,
I think, since February.
We essentially were raising money
for three weeks
So we feel good about what we've done.
There's also a super PAC
that has been supporting our our effort,
which raised another $6 million
on top of that.
So I think we had a pretty good
three weeks.
I want to get your reaction to something
said by the Republican
frontrunner, Donald Trump, last night
about the criminal charges
that he's facing now
and perhaps charges
that might be pending. Take a listen.
Every time the radical
left, Democrats,
Marxists, communists
and fascists, indict me,
I consider it
to be a great badge of honor and courage.
I'm doing it for you.
I'm being indicted for you.
Better me than you, right?
Great badge of honor and courage.
Better than better me than you.
What do you make of that?
He's a liar and a coward.
He's not giving interviews
for anyone other
than because of his own conduct.
There's no other
of the 200 million Americans
you spoke about
who illegally retained
classified national secrets
after being asked
politely, quietly and professionally
for 18 months
to voluntarily
turn them back over
after he left the White House.
There's no other of those
200 million Americans
who lied to their own lawyers
about where those documents were.
And there's none of those other
200 million Americans
who lied to the prosecutors about it
and flashed around documents
regarding an Iranian war plan
to people who didn't have
the clearance to see them.
Look, he's indicted
because of his outrageous conduct,
and that's why he's been indicted.
He now has the opportunity to go to court
and make the government prove
that case beyond a reasonable doubt.
But now he says he doesn't
want to have a trial
until after the election in 20, 24.
I don't think he's doing that for us
either.
He should resolve this thing
before people vote
so that we know exactly
who we're voting for.
To put behind the desk
in the Oval Office.
He says he's doing it for us.
That's a lie.
And what he was doing,
all the things that he was doing
with those documents
it shows exactly what a coward he is.
I know
you just mentioned your super PAC
and I know you're
legally not allowed
to coordinate with your super PAC.
So you might be seeing this ad
I'm about to play for the first time.
But I want to play you a video
that your super PAC is
going to release tomorrow.
Should you show up to the debate?
Because if you do,
your opponents
will bring up the impeachment,
the indictments,
bring up how you lost to Joe Biden.
So, Donald, you need to decide,
are you a chicken or just a loser?
They're calling him a chicken or a loser.
I guess they have to
he has to make a choice there.
What's your reaction to this ad?
Well, it's the first time
I've seen it,
but I think it's probably
a pretty good question.
And he should show up at the debates
and defend his record.
The Republican Party voters
who are deciding
who our nominee should be
should be able to make that decision
by comparing all the candidates
who qualify for the debate stage
right next to each other,
challenging each other's records,
discussing each other's plans
for the future of America
and how they're going to beat Joe Biden.
And we're happy
because now, Jake,
almost 45,000 individual donors
went to Chris Christie dot
com and donated that.
We have qualified for the debate stage
will be there on August 23rd
and we'll be waiting for Donald Trump.
But let me be candid here.
You are starting to gain
some ground in New Hampshire.
But Donald Trump is still leading by
about 20 points just in New Hampshire.
He's up in Iowa. He's up nationally.
Is it
not just a fact
that as of now, Donald Trump remains
far and away
the choice of Republican voters?
Even if you cannot understand why
Well, no.
The fact is that
he's ahead in the polls right now, Jake.
You have reported that accurately.
I'll fact check you
and that is a correct fact
that you've put forward.
But you know,
the good news
is that no one's voting in Iowa
till January 15th.
No one's
probably early voting in New Hampshire
till later that month or early February.
And there's a lot of campaign to go here.
In fact,
we haven't even had the first debate
yet, as you mentioned.
So lots of August.
23rd,
I think most people, let's say in
my region of the country
are down to the Jersey Shore right now,
enjoying their summer vacation,
maybe in New Hampshire
at Lake Winnipesaukee.
They're not focused on this yet.
Just you
and I
are in a few other
candidates so let's get people focused
when we get here.
Late summer, early fall.
Let's engage in intellectual.
We talk about,
you know, some very simple issues, Jake.
You know, first is, you know,
are you going to get the truth?
You deserve the truth
as a Republican primary voter
and as an American.
And will you get a candidate
who will make the truth important?
We know Donald Trump hasn't done that.
And will you get
someone who will deliver results
on the issues that you care about?
You know, Donald Trump was arguing again
last night about immigration.
He didn't do anything
to change the immigration laws
to make them better
or stronger for America.
And he built 47 miles of new wall.
I mean, his four years as president
you know, Jake,
at that rate,
he would need 110 more years as president
to be able to finish the wall
between the United States and Mexico.
The first debate as you note, now
almost a month away.
I want you to take a listen to what
your fellow
2024 candidate, former Texas
Congressman Will Hurd,
had to say
about those
who take the debate pledge
to support the eventual nominee.
This is what he had to
say a couple of weeks ago.
I can't lie
to get access to a microphone.
I'm not going to support Donald Trump.
I recognize the impact
it has
on on on my ability
to get access to the debate stage.
But I can't lie.
It'll be easy to say I'll do it.
And then when it comes down
you know, change your mind.
But I just can't I can't do that
in your. I'm sorry.
And Will Hurd's formulation,
are you lying to make the debate stage
by signing a pledge
to support the nominee,
no matter who it is, including
if it's Donald Trump
Well, I won't see,
I won't see
will hurt on the debate stage.
And that's okay by me.
The fact is, we've got to change
our party, Jake, and change our country.
And we had these debate pledges
eight years
ago, as you'll recall,
and all of us sign them.
And then when we got on the debate stage
and we were asked to reaffirm
it, Donald Trump
refused to raise his hand.
The only one of the ten candidates
who did.
The fact is,
he has set the precedent here.
And I will sign the debate pledge
and I will take it every bit
as seriously as he did in 2016.
New Jersey Governor Chris Christie,
thanks so much for joining us today.
Appreciate it.
Jake, thanks for having me.
I appreciate it.